Шановні колеги я думаю що всі ми уважно
слухали а-а дебати на Гена асамблеї ООН
і раді Безпеки ООН що стосувалися війни
розв'язаної російської Федерацією проти
України Так от На жаль тема незаконно
організованих Російською Федерацією
виборів на окупованих територіях в цих
виступах не звучала тому сьогоднішня
наша голосування за цю Постанову
співавтором якої я і представники
європейської солідарності надзвичайно
важлива Ми ніколи не визнаємо цих
виборів ми засуджуємо їх проведення
нелегітимними є всі ці так звані
псевдооргани влади і безумовно мають
бути посилені санкції і проти російської
федерації і проти всіх організаторів цих
нелегітимних виборів також треба
посилити тиск на Росію щодо незаконної
паспортизації громадян України Це є
частина геноцидної політики але зверніть
увагу російська ситуація зараз
формується незаконні органи влади і хто
туди заходить колаборанти представники
заборонених партій шарійці опзж і на
жаль слуги народу і тому зараз мій
заклик до правлячої партії ви маєте
провести негайно очищення ваших рядів
від цих покидьків яких ви набрали у
ваших списки і вони зрадили сьогодні не
так вашу команду то таке вони зрадили
Україну і так само як вони прийшли в
слуги народа тільки заробляти і тиріть
так зараз вони стали колаборантами
зрадниками і причетні до незаконних
виборів до цих незаконних органів влади
причетні до того що вони катують
українців збирають списки проукраїнських
людей це абсолютно ганьба європейська
Солідарність сьогодні 2,5 тисячі наших
партійців воюють на фронті А тих хто
негідно себе веде в місцевих органах
влади ми і вчора повичищали на нашому
частині нашого з'їз Ду беріть приклад з
європейською солідарності і вичистіть
ваші